the government levied a tax on Christmas
trees to advertise Christmas trees
nervous about the rising popularity of
artificial trees Christmas tree
producers banded together to Lobby the
US Department of Agriculture to create
the Christmas tree promotion board to
strengthen the position of fresh cut
Christmas trees in the marketplace the
image campaign would be funded by a
mandatory 15 cent fee on every live tree
sold a fee paid by tree producers but
passed on to Consumers public outcry
stalled the implementation of the fee
for a time but was fully implemented by
2015 because taxes are the price we pay
for Christmas yes this really happened